Michael I've known you since you were
a child
you have a gift
you always have if there's an answer to
the disease we'll find it
I should have died years ago
why am I still here if not to fix this I
have a rare blood disease and I'm
runnin' out of time video
this could be my last chance
you're up to something what is it
it's not exactly legal
I don't want to see you get hurt more
than you already have this would be a
cure
at what cost
I went from dying
I'm feeling more alive than ever.
increased strength and speed
the ability to use echolocation
an overpowering urge to consume blood
how far are we allowed to go
we'll fix something that's broken
until the remedy
is worse than the disease
Michael Morbius got tired of doing the
whole good guy thing. What's up what's up doc?
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my Morbius trailer breakdown
what universe are we in because we have
spider-man and we have the vulture in
this movie so we get a lot of stuff to
talk about and it all seems like it's in
service of a big sinister six team-up
eventually if you're new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the
easter-egg videos we're doing a movie
ticket giveaway - all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
biggest theory about that big cameo
during the trailer so I know everybody's
wondering what's the deal with
spider-man showing up with the
graffiti behind him in the prison garb
as he's walking by this is all happening
in New York City as you can see from a
lot of the other shots in the trailer
the flashbacks also take place in New
York City and then also Michael Keaton's
vulture character shows up at the end of
the trailer looking like he just broke
out of prison because he's bringing the
exact same outfit that he was during the
spider-man homecoming post-credits scene
totally mind-blowing and on top of that
the picture of spider-man on the wall
there with that seems like it's
meant to imply the events of spider-man
far from home like everyone thinks that
he got Mysterio so they think of him
as a you'll notice that the
costume isn't the MCU Tom Holland
costume that he ends in spider-man far
from home it's actually the Tobey
Maguire era spider-man costume in the
picture itself is based on the
spider-man ps4 a game it's literally
like a screen cap that they took at a
spider-man ps4 so either someone is just
messing with us a little bit or they're
just mixing and matching a whole lot of
elements from MCU Tom Hollands
spider-man stuff in the new Sony venom
verse we knew they were going to cross Tom
Holland over into the venom movies
eventually this just seems like it's all
in service of that eventual crossover
happening way sooner than we ever
expected I wouldn't be surprised if he
actually does show up in venom 2 at some
point but talking about the actual
Morbius footage most of you are probably
stay little familiar with the Morbius
character he was basically Marvel's
attempt to do something based on the
Dracula character the funny thing is is
that Dracula already is a Marvel comic
book character but they wanted to create
a new character so way back in the 1970s
when the Dracula craze around the world
got really really popular
they created the Morbius character and
he's not technically a vampire the way
the
Dracula's a vampire he doesn't get his
abilities through a vampire bite even
though there are a lot of vampire bats
flying around in the trailer they kind
of do their version of the comic book
origin story there's a couple minor
changes but a lot of Easter eggs for the
original version of his origin story the
person it seems like Jared Harris is
playing is actually a version of his
original partner in the comics so in the
comics Morbius is the biological
scientist he has a rare blood condition
just like he talks about during the
trailer he's slowly been dying for a
long time his time is running out but
the testing that he needs to perform on
himself isn't totally legal so they go
out into international waters like where
you see them go to this special cave
with the helicopter that's their version
of doing that in the comics it was a
boat that they went out to on
international waters
Morbius performs a special treatment
using electroshock therapy in the blood
of vampire bats mixed with his own blood
that causes the accident that gives him
his powers cuz basically was playing out
during the trailer here and then because
Jared Harris is sort of this father
figure to him as he says I've known you
since you were a boy and he also seems
like he was a doctor and inspired
Morbius to eventually become a doctor
himself when he grew up in the comics
when he's on that boat with his research
partner and his girlfriend martine
Bancroft who's played by this woman in
the trailer he's immediately driven to
feed through his vampire urges and he
accidentally attacks his research
partner so it seems like this footage in
the trailer is him actually attacking
Jared Harris and accidentally destroying
him without realizing what's going on
like he's using these abilities to jump
around this New York City apartment and
then it jumps on this person you can't
quite see what's going on but then he
screams out in pain so this might be him
accidentally killing Jared Harris right
after he gets his abilities because you
see the montage of the trailer where he
slowly starts to get better but then
they find out that he's starting to turn
into something of a vampire himself like
they put him behind the glass and he
starts punching it so he probably tries
to isolate himself early in the process
while they're figuring out what it is
that's happening to him if you're a big
comic book reader you also probably
notice the other part of his origin
story too with this oil tanker in the
comics after he accidentally kills his
research partner he throws himself
overboard so that he won't be consumed
to feed on his girlfriend Martine
Bancroft
but his survival instincts as a vampire
kick in save him and then he gets
rescued out of the water by this boat of
fishermen he winds up feeding on all
so you see him flying around this oil
tanker boat getting all these people
that's probably their version of that
from the comics Matt Smith is playing
the Loxias crown character so he might
wind up becoming the villain sometime
later in the trailer - it's not really
clear what he's doing in the course of
this trailer footage though because you
just see him on what seems like the
subway platform walking around going
somewhere else in the comics he had the
same rare type of condition that Morbius
had that was destroying him he went through
a similar type of treatment it also got
a bunch of powers but wound up being
super super evil Morbius as you can see
from the trailer is actually getting the
venom treatment as an anti hero inside
this Sony venom verse and now it looks
like connected to the spider-man MCU
universe as well the smokey looking
special effects behind him when he's
flying around using his vampire
abilities remind me a little bit of the
special effects they use for the
Nightcrawler character during x-2 in the
original x-men films the rest of the
trailer is mostly a montage of action
scenes just letting you know what his
abilities look like it's really just
meant to be the teaser trailer and
obviously just give you the big bomb oh
my god this is happening inside the
spider-man universe and we have Michael
Keaton as the vulture coming back from
spider-man homecoming my guess is when
we get to the next trailer there'll be a
little bit more of the story and they'll
reveal a little bit more about what's
going on with the villain because Loxias
crown is meant to be sort of the carnage
for the Morbius character like venom is
meant to be the anti-hero the venom
movies even though technically he's a
spider-man Tolin but then along comes
someone who's even worse that he has to
take down solo cos crown is that for the
Morbius character like I said I'm not
sure why they're using the Sam Raimi
spider-man costume but this is meant to
be taking place after the spider-man far
from home post-credits scene so the
world thinks that he got Mysterio
thanks to J jonah Jameson in that
footage that Mysterio concocted also I
kind of think that there's going to be a
J Jonah Jameson cameo during this there
was a rumor that I talked about in my
last Morbius teaser video now I'm
actually starting to believe it because
Michael Keaton just showed up and we got
confirmation on this spider-man Easter
Egg the other really big actor that's in
this is Tyrese it just seems like he's
one of the feds who's coming for Morbius
and then finds out that eventually
during the course of the movie that he's
not evil there's someone that's even
worse the Loxias crown character and
maybe they wind up teaming up to take
them down Tyrese also signed a multi
picture deal so whatever big team up
that Morbius
with venom whatever maximum carnage
storyline that they have with spider-man
Tyrese will also be part of that too
then at the end of the trailer they gave
you the full-on Morbius treatment this
is what he'll look like when he is in
full vampire form so maybe for this
version of the movie they're going to allow
him to transform back and forth between
his more human looking form and the
vampire form in the comics for the most
part he's locked into this one form
until he finds a treatment that
eventually cures him and then he
eventually gets his powers back I know a
lot of you were wondering if they're
going to do this special spider-man
storyline where he gets the multiple
arms because that's the story line that
Morbius debuted during in the spider-man
comics amazing spider-man back to her in
the early 1970s I don't think that Tom
Holland is going to show up in this movie
with six arms that would just be
completely weird but it would be funny
if there was an Easter Egg for that
somewhere during the movie the whole
thing about his introduction in the
comics is that it's actually part of a
Spider Man lizard story with Curt
Connors they're both looking for
something to cure their condition and
they find that Morbius his blood will do
that so Morbius is more of a villain
when he shows up in the spider-man
comics for the first time but eventually
it's a very venom movie type of twist
where he's like I'm only going to feed
on people that are bad I'm only going to
hurt people that are evil as far as the
Michael Keaton vulture cameo it does
look like he just broke out of prison
because he's wearing the exact same
outfit so I don't know what Morbius is
doing in this prison outfit either
because he's wearing a completely
different prison uniform but the line of
dialogue so you got tired of doing the
whole good guy thing makes it sound like
maybe he breaks a bunch of people out of
prison himself I was a little upset that
we didn't get a follow up to the
spider-man homecoming post-credits scene
during spider-man far from home but it
seems like they were saving that for the
Morbius movie in this venom first tying
it all together it does seem like it's
all in service of a sinister six team up
movie however they're going to
accomplish that
remember the sony is also developing a
craven movie for the craven character
and there is a craven truck that shows
up somewhere during the Morbius movie
this is actually screen grabbed from
behind the scenes while they were
shooting so regardless of when that
sinister six movie is going to happen
they are definitely setting that up in
this movie let me know in the comments
though we all kind of figured that they
would head for a maximum carnage team-up
because of the venom movies but do you
actually think that they're going to get
two sinister sticks faster than they get
to maximum carnage or do you think there
can I do maximum carnage at all and
they'll just go straight to sinister six
I think when they announced the Morbius
movie most people were like why are they
doing Morbius I don't understand he's
not that big of a character
now everyone's heads have turned around
and they're like you had my curiosity
but now you have my attention so I think
like a bunch of people are just going to
show up just to see how this is
connected to the MCU version of
spider-man and Tom Holland for now my
expectations are the Tom Holland does
not appear himself in this movie maybe
they use some stock footage from the end
of spider-man far from home but for the
most part I think that they're very
light touches when it comes to physical
actual spider-man appearing and some of
this stuff I would be a little bummed
out if Tom Holland appeared physically
in the Morbius movie before he appeared
in a venom crossover so I think that
they're still negotiating to get him
into venom to in some sort of post
credits scene or something like that but
the cool thing is is that venom 2 is
coming out in October so we'll probably
get the first trailer for that when the
Morbius movie comes out this summer the
Morbius movie is being released right
after Comic Con so we're not going to have
to wait that long to find out what's
going on with venom and carnage they'll
probably drop some early teasers before
that - so everyone post your theories in
the comments below I'll name a giveaway
winner the next time I post a Marvel
video let me know in the comments is
there any big follow-up videos that you
want me to do based on the Easter eggs
and this and all the spider-man stuff
while you wait for everything click here
for that brand new Iron Man announcement
video and click here for my brand-new
Deadpool 3 video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight!